et on commence par le fils c'est du
président mitterrand qui se retrouve en
prison jean christophe mitterrand le
fils de l'ancien président de la
république a été mis en examen et écroué
à la prison de la santé dans une affaire
de trafic d'armes explication olivier
caroff
à cet instant jean christophe mitterrand
ne sait pas encore ce qui l'attend
convoqué à la brigade financière hier
matin le voici huit heures plus tard
emmené dans le bureau d'un juge
d'instruction
ce magistrat philippe courroye est
chargé d'une affaire de blanchiment
d'argent et de ventes d'armes il a déjà
fait incarcérer un certain pierre
falcone accusé d'être un trafiquant de
matériel militaire et ce sont justement
sur ses relations avec pierre falcone
que jean christophe mitterrand va être
interrogé trois heures durant puis mise
en examen rien n'est un examen sur quoi
on n'a pas bien compris
si il est mis en examen pour recel
d'abus de biens sociaux parce qu'il a
touché des fonds c'est tout ah non il
est aussi mis en examen pour trafic
d'influencé sur autorités publiques n'a
pas compris et il n'y a pas l'ombre d'un
début d'explication de la part du
magistrat instructeur du parquet rien
rien vous êtes supposé avoir commis un
trafic d'influencé passif une autorité
étrangère l'autorité française rien pour
l'avocat de jean christophe mitterrand
la première bataille consistera à faire
sortir son client de prison car le juge
courroye a tranché le fils de l'ancien
président de la république et placé en
détention provisoire à la maison d'arrêt
de la santé
la justice le soupçonne d'avoir reçu une
commission sur une vente d'armes près de
deux millions de dollars environ 13
millions de francs virés sur un compte
en suisse par pierre falcone jean
christophe mitterrand lui explique ce
virement par son rôle de conseil
politico économique et nie toute
implication
avec des ventes d'à
paul loup sulitzer lui aussi placé en
garde à vue hier à livrer sensiblement
les mêmes explications pour justifier
les sommes que lui a versés pierre
falcone
actuellement le débat porte sur une
somme d'un million deux cent mille
francs d'accord il était le conseiller
de monsieur falcone il faisait avec
monsieur falcone prestation
qu'il appartiendra le quai de queyries
avec ce dossier la justice se plonge
pour la première fois dans les
opérations plus ou moins opaque de la
france en afrique sous françois
mitterrand un temps responsable de la
cellule africaine de l'elysée jean
christophe mitterrand est la première
personnalité politique rattrapé par la
sphère mail enquêtes portent aussi sur
les années 93 et 94 en pleine
cohabitation
savinykh verdeilhan